good afternoon I'm Beth Cheney I'm the
co-chair of this event and we're in the
final stretch of today's program I hope
that everyone has been enjoying the aya
75th Assembly as much as I have it's
been exciting to celebrate our Yale
community's hundredth year history of
leading the way in public health is my
distinct privilege to introduce our
final speaker for this afternoon she's a
dear friend to many of us here at AOA
and at Yale she has many titles but the
one that we love here at aya and the one
that I share with her is former Board of
Governor member Marta Murat is president
of urban policy strategies and an
organization which provides program
evaluation and technical assistance to
community-based health organizations she
will speak to us on what you can do to
advance public health please join me in
welcoming her
okay I've discovered that I can't see
over that Oh has this been a remarkable
day or what now one workshop has not
been exciting controversial in mean it's
just been an incredible day and I just
want you to know that since you know
I've had a relatively calm couple of
weeks and haven't needed anything
exciting like this I was prepared to you
know just go through the motions but I'm
completely passionately excited by about
what's happened so let me talk to you
about I guess my title is what you can
do to advance public health but I wanted
to first talk to you about why I
personally am so excited about public
health it is a tremendous honor that
Paul and Jeanette have given me to do
the closing remarks here and I can't
tell you how excited I am about it
because it was here in the School of
Public Health that I really discovered
the importance of health equity and I
discovered what poverty can do to
children's health somewhere in the 60s
just before I came to the public health
school I went to visit family in Puerto
Rico and a lot of my family live in that
Central Corridor of the island that is
probably the poorest and the most rural
in the island and I saw things that made
me feel like I said you know why do
children have to be the victims of lack
of money that results in parents having
to choose for food instead of
vaccinations why I said to myself do
families rely on health belief
that in the long run can jeopardize
further the health of children and what
kind of a government do we have in
places like Puerto Rico and other
countries where they are allowed through
a program called Operation bootstrap in
the 30s and 40s to experiment with women
on reproduction and to sterilize women
as a process of that on without their
knowledge or why is it a government
would allow pharmaceuticals to pollute
the waters so that those toxins have an
effect on the lives of children as they
grow up in the future those are the
things that I saw for the first time
having lived in well first the South
Bronx but then later in Litchfield
County where you don't see this kind of
poverty and I recognize I wanted to do
something about that and so I came to
Yale to acquire the tools to promote
this kind of health work and today I
used to anyway before something happened
a couple years ago I run urban policy
policy strategies I work in with
communities with African Americans
Latinos Native Americans I work with
documented and undocumented citizens and
and we work on on issues related to
something called community participatory
research in which I have worked with
these nonprofit organizations in these
communities not just to evaluate whether
the programs that they're running
whether it's a program to prevent HIV or
a program to treat substance abuse or a
program to improve maternal child care
outcomes we not only do the evaluation
with them but we make them partners in
that evaluation process so
for what reason for the best reason of
all when we finish the evaluation and I
have given my report to whoever I need
to give my report to they can take those
data and those data can become campaign
platforms for getting more money and
sustaining the programs they can be used
to educate their communities and their
families they can be used further to
work with researchers to create journal
articles and to move the public policy
dialogue because after all that's what
public health is about that's what all
looking at bugs talking about the
Affordable Care Act talking about our
and all of that that's what public
health is about is ultimately changing
the environment in which we live and as
Jeanette says it's daring to imagine for
a better life so the final reason why
I'm in in public health is that it links
me to a man who was at the time equally
committed to community research and I
had we of course fell in love we got
married and I had high dreams that we
were going to join the Peace Corps or we
were gonna go to South America or Africa
join our two skills in psychology and
public health and and work on research
projects and imagine my surprise look at
me now so let me try in just a few
minutes now to put all of this together
for you and and see if there's some
takeaway points from what we've gone
through today because there was so much
today wasn't there and I mean and every
single one of the workshops I don't know
about you but I wanted to stay for a la
I was ready to stay for a lot longer and
have continued conversations about what
was going on so I came up with three
points to kind of pull together the rich
flavor of today in a way that I hope and
Jeanette and Paul and I hope that you
are too
related to continued work in this public
health field in one way or another point
one there is no question after you hear
Paul Cleary's remarks about the
multidisciplinary work that the public
health schools the multidisciplinary
environments in which the public health
area happens that public health is
universally integrated into our lives
even as it keeps the water clean and
ensures that disease carrying rats are
no longer running around in our streets
and even as we eradicate in control
communicable diseases from our myths its
presence grows ever larger in our lives
this morning dr. Cleary talked about a
new Yale public health school I think
you saw that not just in the in the work
that with the [ __ ] the film that we saw
but also in the workshops the
multiplicity of the aspects of Public
Health
number two the strong use of
interdisciplinary approach there is a
young woman I met at lunch and we've
been talking through this because she's
very interested in what the School of
Public Health is going to do around
environmental health and how do you get
into it who would have thought decades
ago that public health would be an
integral part of environmental health of
climate change of all the things that
you have heard today number three the
part of that universe universality of
public health is the passion have you
met anyone today in public health who
teaches public health who talks about
public health who sits in any of these
workshops have you met anyone today
who isn't extraordinarily passionate
about this in fact you're a leader of
the aya leaned over to me this morning
and says oh now I see why you went to
public health school
and so we have shown that universal
universality in several ways in
education for instance we now know for
sure after all the back and forth around
the data that headstart actually works
but why big issue is we know that
children learn early in school and they
get readiness skills to go on and so
that's been a big part of the research
showing that in fact kids live better
lives but we are also vaccinate children
early in headstart so there is access to
early early care kids are observed by
teachers and we pick up early diagnosis
of learning disabilities of mental
health issues that and other kinds of
issues that may block their ability to
become successful students in school and
hopefully what we see with the
combination of public health approaches
early education approaches we're seeing
that those children grow into
responsible human beings they don't drop
out they don't become pregnant out of
wedlock they don't produce have
pregnancy problems and birth problems
they don't end up unemployed they don't
end up using drugs and getting into
problems ending up incarcerated and
worse ultimately dying because of street
violence so we're seeing those kinds of
potentials in a program like Head Start
so the question is is Head Start a
public health component you bet
absolutely because it fulfills those
issues that you've heard some of today
about social indicators of health we are
now recognizing as you must have heard
today that health is not just about
medicine it's not just about brushing
your teeth two times a day
whatever number of days you know we can
do it public health is also about you
can't be a healthy person if your family
has no money how are they going to make
decisions about sending you to the
doctor or giving you vaccinations if
they're worried about money it's always
a trade-off as to what we pay for today
and what we pay off tomorrow if you're
unemployed if you're living in
substandard housing we're by the way
they're still dealing with lead
poisoning and they're still dealing with
the effects of pesticides in public
housing these are the kind of things
that make social determinants of health
very important another piece of the
universality of public health is the
environment the debate goes on about
whether we're actually heading into
global warming but the data don't lie we
are seeing more incidences of
respiratory illnesses we're seeing
issues related to disease insect
diseases that are transferring to human
human illness we're actually seeing more
cases of melanoma and cancers as a
result of the increasing changes in the
the sun's UV H approaches um and in the
military you would think Public Health
in the military but think about it we
are sending our young people to the
Middle East to god-knows-where
and what used to be an issue of combat
fatigue is now post-traumatic stress
disorder it's definable it has
components it's treatable it's part of
the mental health system their public
health is involved we also have people
who are in military occupations that are
having exposures in Vietnam auras Agent
Orange in some of the Middle East Wars
it's respiratory illnesses related to
some of the infections in the same
and earth they fly around in the
environment so we are now as a result of
public health research and and
involvement able to address the needs of
our military people and address those
needs in a responsible way again another
another wonderful part of what we're
doing here and so we move to point two
of public health we know it's universal
we know it's gotten it's in every aspect
of everything we do you came here
thinking you were gonna learn about
public health and now you realize so
much of what you do on a daily basis is
related to public health every time you
pick up the newspaper it's related to
public health but here's the other part
about public health public health is
really unsexy so how many ads on
television do you see for Oh brush your
teeth three times a day don't forget to
floss don't forget to eat fresh fruit
fruits and vegetables I know that
Jeanette and I are trying to do a lot of
work in the community around nutrition
you hardly ever see except for those
bars that are filled with you know tons
and tons of salt but what you do see are
insurance companies and pharmaceuticals
who are willing to sell you an easy cure
don't want to lose the fat go get our
ice sculpting or chin lifting or lip
puffing or whatever it is your need to
make you look better without having to
give up those chocolates um you have a
wreck tile dysfunction please don't tell
me
don't worry about it there's a pill for
that you have cholesterol problems you
want to bike into the future with your
spouse and and look healthy and young
and wonderful take a pill but to do
prevention work is harder because when
we do the research we now know that the
monies that go for medications and
pharmaceuticals and for insurance
companies to do their work has to be
approved through the federal government
forgive me if I'm sounding like Bernice
wanders here but the issue is this when
we used to testify before Congress and
say smoking causes lung cancer and they
say so everyone who smokes MS marette
gets lung cancer I said well the
probability that they will get lung
cancer it is high yeah but what's a
probability we want to know that there's
a direct association between that
cigarette stick and the cancer that they
develop but we can't say that because we
are researchers who are not going
because some 90 year old person will
hobble over into the Congressional scene
and say I've been smoking three packs
for 90 years and I have no cancer so
what they're more likely to fund are the
interventions that are medically
oriented what we want to do is not
prevent cancer cure cancer and so we're
gonna spend money to treat you through
surgery keep you in the hospital for as
long as the DRGs let you stay in the
hospital and we're going to treat you
with long-term chemotherapy that is
costly invasive and depressing if
nothing else so our our government is
more inclined to to go into those areas
than they are and working on the
prevention side only a sliver of the
federal budget is committed to
prevention so you can see that the
public health school and public health
as a discipline is never going to go out
of fashion because the idea of
preventing illness improving health is
always going to be a part of this and I
think you saw this in our discussions
here today now a third point which i
think is going to be which which is a
personal favorite of mine I kept seeing
it over and over in the discussions
today and all I could come up with is
public health is like the Sir Lancelot
of King Arthur's Court whenever there is
a major outbreak of something horrific
like Ebola or SARS on an ocean liner or
Legionnaires disease or any of those
things who comes to the rescue
covered in a white plastic sheet and
gloves and a mask why it's our public
health people and they look at it they
investigate it and they get a solution
quickly think it is no small matter that
when the Ebola crisis broke out think of
the infection that happened and that
within 12 to 24 hours that American
individual was on a plane and in the
United States with the possibility of
Ebola if we did not have the standards
that we have in public health now that
person might have contracted Ebola might
have spread it to other people so our
practices and processes to prevent
outbreaks of disease are indeed yeomen
work on the part of Sir Lancelot of
Public Health okay those are my three
points there are probably others you can
come up with and I
sure tonight over drinks we'll talk
about more of them so what is it that
you can do about public health now in
addition to having gotten my degree in
public health and being a now very
permanent resident of Yale University I
am a proud alum of of the aya and I
actually indeed served on the board we
had very rowdy and wonderful days on
that board of governors do not talk to
anybody about it but we were pretty bad
you know what is it that we as alums can
do we come from a wide variety of
disciplines we come to an assembly like
this to learn about what a school that
we may never have taken a course from or
been involved in does what would we want
to do when we realize that the issues of
public health are there all over the
place and so a few weeks ago I had the
distinct pleasure of giving Barbara Bush
class of 2004 the Distinguished Service
Award for her work in the founding of
something called Global Health Corps and
it was to the Yale alumni nonprofit
alliance this young woman has had
hundreds of young people from colleges
all over the country come to Yale for
two weeks learn about public health
learn about outreach learn about
community service and then she sends
them to Europe to Burundi to Kenya to
South Africa they're all there doing
amazing work and she decided to do this
when she was talking with her father
you know George
and he and she started to develop a
foundation on AIDS prevention and
because he said in in this way that I'll
never forget that even after you've done
public service as president of the
United States your commitment to public
service never ends and I can't think of
a better way to do that than in serving
global health pretty nice considering
how his father treats him in his book so
we are seeing dozens of examples at Yale
of young innovative people could there
be anything more innovative more
polished more amazing than the young
people that presented here today
unbelievable my mouth was a GOG because
these are the young people that are
going to change the world in the future
they so strongly believe in the
innovations that they have created that
I have no doubt that they will be
successful and in part we know this is
alumni we know this is jelly's that when
you come to you you want to change the
world and that's why you come and these
kids were prime examples of that so what
would you want to do about that would
you want to do scholarships would you
want to be involved in finding out what
happens in public health and these very
different kinds of things that are going
on I just want to talk a minute about
one way in which you can be useful in
the places from which you come and that
is we've done a lot of talking today
about global health and I think that is
absolutely an critic
important because the world is much
smaller than it ever has been and it's
important to continue strong work in
global health but let's look at our own
backyard for a moment
and jennette knows what I'm talking
about we are in a university a city that
hosts us called New Haven it's a great
city of 350,000 people wonderful
restaurants you can eat a different
restaurant every night for weeks it has
a great government structure it has fine
housing and when you look at some of the
health indices that Jeanette and her
wonderful team at Kerr looked at in
doing the community health assessment
you see the Connecticut doesn't look so
bad compared to the rest of Connecticut
even though it's the third largest state
and one of the third poorest town in the
state it doesn't even look bad compared
to the United States around some indices
up oh wait there's a rub look beyond the
restaurants look beyond the wealth look
beyond the ivied walls of Yale go to the
places that Jeanette and I go anybody
took the tour of New Haven a couple of
you did go to those places and see what
we know is this about almost 30 percent
of the population that live in some of
these neighborhoods are african-american
Latino Native American documented and
undocumented immigrants and now refugees
they are either under employed so that
they can barely afford the insurance
that the Affordable Care Act is trying
to provide for them or they are
unemployed and therefore eligible for
Medicaid which is good but may have some
other issues that are worth discussing
they live in substandard housing and we
already talked about lead poisoning
and pesticides they they are probably
involved in all kinds of behavioral
health issues that puts them at risk for
all of the public health things we've
been talking about poor birth outcomes
substance abuse I worked in those
neighborhoods in the early 80s on
hiv/aids doing education and outreach
around condom use and all of that those
individuals in within the city of the
city of New Haven should have as Harlan
said today Harlan krumholz there is a
need for equitable treatment of those
families why whether we think that
people got poor because they wanted to
be poor or they're the third generation
of regardless of any of that
you want people to excel and to be
productive members of their society
because number one they do give back to
the society and they do give in terms of
money but number two will have fewer
people in the emergency rooms who use it
as the primary care setting we have
fewer people with more chronic cancer
rates than the average person higher
rates of smoking and lung cancer higher
rates of colorectal cancer more of those
people may be involved in prevention
programs they may think it might even be
worth it to come to a nutrition
education program because they have the
time and the commitment and they're not
pulled in four different directions
for survival so if you wanted to be
involved and in I I would like to make
about three suggestions to you number
one I don't know how Janette will feel
about this but if I were you and I was
head of my Yale Club
I would be on the phone asking genetic
Yvette's to come out and talk to us
about community public health I would
want her to talk about how do you do
community health assessments how do we
know what's happening in our communities
in Chicago in Minnesota in Austin Texas
how do we know what's going on there how
do we do a community health assessments
very few communities do that they're
very expensive they're very time
consuming but they're an opportunity to
build something that Hall loves to talk
about collaboration so the communities
collaborate and from that you can then
move forward to a strategic model maybe
look for funding from a Robert Wood
Johnson or other to address some of
these specific needs so that's one
Avenue and if and if her and if her
dance card gets full and she has too
many of these things to do you can
always invite me to continue the
missionary statements on on this kind of
thing number two
we now have something call the
Affordable Care Act and we had a
workshop today that I think those of you
who attended will probably will might
agree with me that it just did not cover
what the Affordable Care Act is it's a
it's a very complicated piece of
legislation that is in evolution with
strong attempts to D evolute it 52
attempts to to get rid of this bill by
the Republicans we need to understand
what it means it's like an elephant in
the room depending on what side of the
elephant you touch either this is great
because I'm uninsured and now I have
insurance this is not great on middle
class I'm low income and my my insurance
premiums just were not you know fifty
percent so what is it what are the
services that we're getting under it
the best thing we can do as Yale EES is
learn about the Affordable Care Act
ignorant is a dangerous thing it's
important if you're against the
Affordable Care Act to know why and to
know why you have to know what it is and
what those nine hundred some odd pages
mean for you for families in your
community for the poor for the rich for
the middle class it's just imperative
this bill is in the ring it's going to
go through a lot of changes but I will
tell you something it ain't going away
it's here to stay
regardless of what happens and if it
stays in its present makeup it's it's
got problems and it's incomplete and for
you to be involved as strong
intellectuals from this university to be
able to talk with all the legislators
that you know all the foundation and
policy people that you guys know to talk
about this bill wisely to ask important
intelligent questions about it is
imperative because part of that image of
the future that Jeanette talks about is
a future with a new kind of health care
that delivers health care equitably
low-cost and universally so know that
that is coming and that will be here and
it's best to be informed about what's
going to happen okay my third suggestion
to you is know about what Yael is doing
in public health from an
interdisciplinary perspective all of you
come from different disciplines whether
it's Yale college or graduate school or
professional school and what we learn
this morning is that the public health
school
is nothing if it is not
multidisciplinary there is now a center
for law at the law school that is in
partnership with the law programs here
in the public health school the school
of organization and management is
looking at this public policy
institutions are looking at what's
happening in public health this is a
great time to look and see where those
multi disciplinary approaches are think
about what you want might want to know
more of either through online education
through attending more things to having
speakers from those various places come
or or in be involved in supporting maybe
a faculty member or a project that you
think worthy of promoting the concept of
a multidisciplinary approach in public
health and then the last thing I would
suggest you is talk to me I am after all
the wife of the President and I am here
all the time
I see the wonderful stuff that happens
at Yale Peter has to work I have the
luxury of going out to different
departments talking to alumni to
different groups and seeing the richness
of what we have at Yale even these past
two weeks
even though Peter will talk to you about
them these past two weeks in the long
run have been good for you why because
they're pushing the envelope the way
young people have to push the envelope
the way you as students at Yale push the
envelope much to the chagrin of your
elders so I would be delighted if you
you know emailed me or calls me or
whatever and link you up with an
interest you might have this is how I
was able to link up a young alum who is
interested in starting a museum
New York City on climate change and its
impact on human health and we linked her
to several people at the environmental
school and some people at the public
health school and she's been doing a
great job these are the kind of links
that are important use people like me
question people you know Peter has an
honorary appointment here or a real
appointment I don't know he's at the the
Center for interdisciplinary research on
AIDS which was not discussed too much
today but it's an important center that
has looked at all of the multi-faceted
aspects of HIV as a global and a local
issue and you know he has done public
health work looking at how people accept
messages that will change their behavior
and someday other than having him talk
about emotional intelligence you might
or jealousy which is another one of his
areas I had nothing to do with that he
also he also talks about how you make
the what kind of messages you sent out
to change behavior a quick example
you know those television ads where they
show someone with their throat wide open
because they've been smokers and now
they've got a hole they apparently don't
work other kinds of messages work and he
would know about that he would love to
talk about that so with that I will
leave you to enjoy the rest of the
afternoon and look forward to seeing you
all at the cocktail hour tonight and
thank you once again for coming and
doing this great work
please join me in thanking Marta and all
of our speakers and presenters today for
a truly insightful and energetic
assembly
I do have one piece of housekeeping
before I have some a few closing remarks
I'm told there is a hearing aid that's
been found and if anyone has that please
see one of the aya one of the aya in the
back if you're looking for it so I don't
know about you but I've just been blown
away by today's assembly we've heard
some of the leaders in their field
speaking on a range of topics from
cancer care to climate change and a
focus to New Haven to global refugee
crisis public health at Yale affects all
of us both locally and globally and I
hope that you've been as inspired today
as I've been I'd really like to thank my
co-chair Christine Walsh for all her
enthusiasm and support it's really not
easy for two clinicians to juggle
competing schedules but she's been great
and it's really been a pleasure working
with her I hope our goal was to offer
you a rich exciting assembly and a
highlight the school of public health in
their centennial year I'd also really
like to thank the school of public
health especially Janette and Heidi
Richards as well as Dean Cleary
they've just been absolutely amazing to
work with we've had just such a great
time and I hope that you have really
enjoyed what we've had to offer you
today
and finally it goes without saying I'd
be really remiss if I didn't really give
a big shout out to the team here at aya
Bob bonds
he's just extraordinary he really he is
just the he's just a quiet he's just the
quiet force every time I would call him
and I'd be like Bob how's it going he's
just he's just absolutely extraordinary
and while my very dear friend ELISA
Masterson she just really really really
I mean this is just a really many year
dream of mine to be up here standing
doing this
I came to Yale almost actually almost 30
years ago now I worked in the surgical
ICU many of you heard this story and to
be up here in front of you all today
with having co-chaired this assembly is
really a dream come true so I'm just so
grateful for this opportunity
and as you leave here today I want you
to tell your story on social media I
have finally thanks to Kevin Winston I'm
now on Twitter within with that I need
to tell you within five minutes of
getting on Twitter my daughter told me
to get off of Twitter Sheila not even
kidding you five minutes my daughter was
like get off mom so Twitter Instagram
hashtag Yale alumni will be creating a
story fie of this week's events for all
of you to enjoy all of the events that
you may not have gotten to so please you
know continue to tell your stories
throughout today's in tonight's events
and then throughout the rest of the
assembly we're really looking forward to
hearing everything that you've had to
say and then also please join us tonight
at the Yale medal dinner really such a
highlight of tonight today's events we
can continue to assemble and share
stories the vans will be outside to take
people back to various hotels and then
we can convene at the Yale Law School
dining room for reception let me just
see here then for tomorrow some
housekeeping for tomorrow it's an early
start so set your alarm early if you're
going to be for the excuse me the
session with deputy Provost definitely
Spangler and Melanie Boyd it will be
the Yale art gallery lecture hall the
access will be from the York Street
entrance the loading dock interest from
the art gallery will be starting
promptly at 8 o'clock so please set your
alarm I believe there's been a change in
the program for tomorrow and you'll find
a green slip in your in the packet that
you got today and then in closing I'd
like to thank you for an incredible day
of learning about the ways that Yale is
leading the area of Public Health Chris
and I've really really enjoyed working
together with everyone to bring you this
event and we look forward to seeing you
tonight at the Yale medal dinner and I
just like to say again a big shout out
to everyone and thank you very much for
letting us come this I'll be very brief
but let's thank Beth and Chris one more
time and aya I just wanted to close and
I'll really be one moment it was partly
in honor of Marta and thank you very
much I'm a little bit embarrassed but I
wanted to I just wanted to close I've
been at Yale since 1989 half my life if
you're looking or counting and you know
I know for me and for all of us as
alumni as faculty of students Yale is
like family right I mean this is like
our extended family and I was at a
meeting just a few months ago where Juan
Martinez from the children in Nature
Network said family are those who will
join you in action and in that way I
hope that I can count all of you as
family as family at Yale and his family
to help us innovate and collaborate with
Public Health so thank you have a
wonderful evening and rest of the
assembly I look forward to seeing you
throughout the weekend